is
um
yes
where are you going
okay
children children
[Music]
there you go
all right
make sure the band is ready
okay
welcome
[Music]
um well welcome everyone can you all
hear me in the back there and you can
kind of press forward as best you can
without feeling claustrophobic
just do your best
so um
[Music]
so i want to welcome everyone to this
palm sunday um
this i you know the table we've never
we've never done the palm sunday thing
welcome awesome um so i'm really excited
i love kind of entering into the story
and that's kind of our purpose in um in
doing this is that we get to
kind of enact and enter into a story
ourselves so um
for those unfamiliar for those who have
no idea what's going on why people are
holding shrubbery
and standing here
um
so
this is the story goes that the day that
jesus entered jerusalem
the people were shouting things like god
saves um
hallelujah hosanna and they were laying
palm branches on the ground before him
you can kind of think of it like a sort
of royal thing you know when people are
kind of honored especially in that day
they'd be in the dirt and mud and we
kind of grossed the roads so the idea of
laying down the palm branches was just
you know sort of the image of purity um
and honor
so this is what the people did and uh so
this is kind of what we're enacting is
that um grand entrance
into jerusalem so um what we wanted to
i'm going to read a portion from psalm
which is what the people what they were
shouting is it was drawn from this psalm
and then we i will lead you all into the
sanctuary we will probably do a lap i
don't know maybe so many laughs
maybe not maybe just one lap we'll go
around and so i encourage you to um yell
out blessed is he who comes the name of
the lord we don't have to do it like in
unison
and if you want to do i mean you can say
hallelujah praise god you can just be
thinking of the things you're grateful
for um but especially the kids you have
to lead us because the adults you know
they're like stodgy and like well i
don't know if i'm really going to say
anything
you know so
kids
you've got to carry us and then adults
you know please
get into the spirit all right um
so
all right let me start with this uh
psalm 118 verses 1 through 2 and
19-29
says give thanks to the lord for he is
good his love endures forever
let israel say his love endures forever
open for me the gates of the righteous i
will enter and give thanks to the lord
this is the gate of the lord through
which the righteous may enter i will
give you thanks for you answered me you
have become my salvation
the stone the builders rejected has
become the cornerstone the lord has done
this and it is marvelous in our eyes the
lord has done it this very day let us
rejoice today and be glad lord save us
lord grant us success blessed is he who
comes in the name of the lord from the
house of the lord we bless you the lord
is god and he has made his light to
shine on us with thousand hand join in
the festival procession up to the horns
of the altar you are my god and i will
praise you you are my god and i will
exalt you give thanks to the lord for he
is good his love endures forever
[Music]
who comes in the name of the lord
oh
[Music]
praise the lord
hallelujah
[Music]
laughs
oh
[Music]
the name of the lord
with us
[Music]
did
last time together
[Music]
you are good
are good
[Music]
oh he is
you oh good
you're
[Music]
you good
oh
[Music]
you're good
me down
[Music]
you're never gonna let me down
let me down
[Music]
you're
you're good
oh
you are
[Music]
this
is
[Music]
in
yes
[Music]
is
it's in your presence all our fears
[Music]
you are the god who saves us
[Applause]
[Music]
we welcome you here lord jesus
you
[Music]
broken
eyes
[Music]
is
it's in your presence
[Music]
who saves us
lord jesus
[Music]
you are the god who saves us
us
[Music]
it's in your presence
jesus comes to jerusalem as king
after jesus has said this
he went on ahead
going up to jerusalem
as he approached bethphage and bethany
at the hill called the mount of olives
he sent two of his disciples saying to
them
go to the village ahead of you
and as you enter it
you will find a cult tied there
which no one has ever written
untie it
and bring it here
if anyone asks you
why are you untying it
say the lord needs it
those who were sent ahead went and found
it just
as he had told them
as they were in time the cult its owners
asked them why are you untying the cult
they reply the lord needs it
they brought it to jesus
through their cloaks on the cult and put
jesus on it
as he went along people spread their
cloaks on the road
when he came near the place where the
road goes down the mount of olives
the whole crowd of disciples began
joyfully to praise god in loud voices
for all the miracles they had seen
blessed is the king who comes in the
name of the lord
peace in heaven and glory in the highest
some of the pharisees in the crowd said
to jesus teacher rebuke your disciples
i tell you he replied
if they keep quiet
the stones will cry out
[Music]
all this
oh
could all that is
[Music]
you
make beautiful things
things
[Music]
us
out of chaos
[Music]
you
make beautiful things
[Music]
you make me
all things
beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
you
make me
me
[Music]
please
is
[Music]
now
is
[Music]
lift it up
you
made me
[Music]
uh
to come even into the places that we are
ashamed of
even into the areas that we try to hide
even when we put up fronts and we don't
let others in would you come with your
goodness your acceptance your
forgiveness and begin to soften our
hearts and break the chains that hold us
back god would we allow your good work
in our lives to begin bearing fruit
growing patience
kindness
goodness
hopefulness gentleness self-control
long-suffering
god would your seeds plant themselves
deep within us
into the soil where we have thought
things are dead and dying and broken and
worthless and would we begin to see new
life spring up because you are our hope
jesus is coming
he is our hope
he is our way forward
[Music]
jesus do your work in our hearts
we want you to come god
we need you
and we're grateful for your work in our
lives thank you for this time together
jesus
open our ears and let us hear you speak
in your name i pray amen
thank you guys so much y'all can go
ahead and sit down and turn to the
people around you welcome them and make
them feel at home and brett will start
us on our wrestlers
well good evening everyone
grace and peace it is so good to be with
you
and uh for anyone who is late i'm so
sorry
that you missed the extravaganza
we did the whole march around
oh that's amazing uh thank you for
participating in that i hope it's um
a memorable way to enter into the story
even if it you know made you a little
uncomfortable
um i think it's also so powerful for
those kinds of of moments for
um these kiddos over here you know to
it's it's interesting how the faith kind
of just seeps into your bones over time
the stories
you know it's yeah it just gets in you
so i i really want us to um
yeah it's good to participate in those
ways
so um i want to welcome all of you but
uh that of course as always includes
those joining us online
you're not forgotten love you a lot i
hope you're able to kind of in your own
way be able to uh participate in
our palm sunday march with gary had the
iphone he was kind of going around
trying to give the online folks the
experience so we're really glad that
you're with us and uh and as well as
anyone who's new
and maybe just you know kind of starting
to plug in thank you for for being here
with us so it is of course uh the season
of lent um
here at uh not just at the table but
really the global church um and this is
basically
a season of spiritual preparation um as
we approach um really where we are now
which is holy week um which starts of
course with palm sunday today and then
you kind of go into
the whole week with good friday
and then after that of course easter
sunday so um you know here we are it's
been like 40 some odd days and i'm
really excited to be entering into the
season uh with you so um
i do want to encourage you
uh to if i know some of you have like
prior engagements you have work that
goes late or things you know but um if
you're available good friday i really
want to encourage you to um make the
trek and be here it'll be a joint
service with pleasant valley um united
methodist church the this of course is
the folks who own this place and who we
rent from and uh it's gonna be a
beautiful a beautiful service so i
really encourage you to to be here if
you can 7 o'clock on friday
so um
the title of my message this palm sunday
is palm sunday from miracles to maturity
from miracles to maturity and um
this uh of course chris brown has kind
of already read our our passage
so beautifully way to go chris
um
and so i'm not gonna like reread it um
but i did what i want to do tonight is
just zero in on one one little uh line
one verse that's uh from verse 37
and uh it says this when jesus came near
the place where the road goes down the
mount of olives the whole crowd of
disciples began joyfully to praise god
in loud voices
for all of the miracles they had
seen
hopefully from chris's reading from our
march around you could kind of start to
get at least just a little taste of the
energy
and passion of that day
um
because this i mean this is just a
hugely significant moment um
in
uh
the folks who are jesus original
listeners this kind of early church
these early followers of christ this was
such a significant moment that this
moment um when
finally um christ is among them and he's
making his grand entrance into
jerusalem
uh because you see
for so long the way jesus approached his
ministry which is kind of a little bit
strange if you think about it you might
have noticed this if you've ever heard
the gospels he's always trying to keep
it quiet
do you ever notice this like for example
he'll heal someone and he's like shh
don't tell us
if you've read the gospels you know he's
like oh he's doing this like for example
someone who couldn't walk before and all
of a sudden he does a miracle and they
can walk it's like oh my this is like
huge i mean life-changing momentous like
oh my gosh tell everyone
and he's like um okay now go show
yourself to the priest because that was
sort of part of the ritual for him them
to be
initiated back into the community um
fully so like go show yourself to the
priest but um please don't tell anyone
else and of course the gospels always
point out that they went and then it's
like and they told everyone they
encountered you know
like the people weren't having any of it
but jesus is constantly doing this in
fact there's even a little story if
you've uh remember from the gospel of
john it's jesus first miracle in the
gospel of john he's at a wedding and
they're running out of wine
right it's kind of interesting jesus
first miracle was keeping the party
going
and so there they are right and and his
mom uh notices probably you know being
kind of the um in that culture kind of
the one really kind of attuned to
hospitality and such and the whole you
know wedding and she notices they're
running low on wine and uh marriages or
weddings in that day were like multi-day
things so it was you know you kind of
had to like prepare and they're running
low and so she of course
goes to jesus and is like hey uh you
probably noticed um
they are running low on wine and he
literally is like mom why are you
getting me involved in this
he says and this is his line he says you
know my time has not yet come
and then the bible says she went to the
servants and she said just do whatever
he tells you
and sure enough
probably just if he's his mother
he you know does the mural he turns the
water into wine um but you could tell
from his language and the way you know
he's not like super keen on this why um
because he does he has this power he has
this anointing
and
i mean he's he can do spectacular
amazing things it's like his whole
ministry it's constantly doing the
amazing things but then trying to keep
it under wraps uh because this time has
not yet come his time has not yet come
my time has not yet come which is over
and over and over and then suddenly we
come to luke 19 and the time has come
like are you tracking the time has it's
time the people are there it's it's
hosanna it's praise god it's palm
branches he's the king is entering
jerusalem now there's a certain irony
because he's entering not on a war horse
but a donkey that's another sermon for
another time
uh and
right but but silly the king is entering
his kingdom
here we are
it has uh it has begun
and um i think it's such a it's just a
powerful scene because of course who
christ is right god in the flesh among
them uh the the
lion of judah the lamb of god who takes
away the sins of the world and we of
course know where the story is headed we
know there's a certain tragic kind of
turn um followed by hope and healing and
life and right we know the story but the
people there like they don't know it
um and so they're just pumped
you know just pump that the king is
entering his kingdom he's on the side of
the poor he's on the side of the
marginalized he's on the side of the
people
and they're excited um now uh we can
kind of push a little deeper than ask
why why like why in a very practical way
why are they doing this why are they so
excited just because they love jesus or
something but you know what's going on
um
and actually luke tells us right it's
the verse we just read the whole crowd
of disciples began joyfully to praise
god in loud voices did you catch it for
all of the miracles
they had seen what's that what's a
miracle like what's that a picture of
right it's it's a moment
of power
it's a moment of breakthrough
it's it's a moment of victory
and uh and i think in many ways we can
relate to them right because this is
sort of like where faith begins right
it's the sense of like yes god like i i
didn't know if i was gonna make it
through and god brought me through like
i the doctors gave me that dim prognosis
i was like oh my gosh my world's falling
apart and somehow
god has kept me going right it's
miracles that moment when there's too
much month at the end of the money and
you're like oh dear lord and then
somehow god provides yet again
uh it's it's that moment when you're old
clunker of a car you're like this is
it's not gonna make it it's just not
gonna make it and somehow that old
clunker just keeps on clunking like it
just keeps going right and um
like these are these are the moments
where we just we experience god we
experience his faithfulness we
experience his um provision it's the
moment of miracle and to that we often
say like hallelujah you know even in
conversation with people be like praise
god he just keeps me going you know like
this is kind of the language and that's
that's basically what the people are
doing right there the miracles have been
happening the power's been happening the
victory and breakthrough and yes god's
on our side so the people they're pumped
up
and um
so in many ways that's kind of the
prelude like so there they stand
and to enter into the story there we
stand with them
shouting hosanna shouting praise god and
and there we are in the gates of
jerusalem are just looming before us
and christ is about to enter
but here's the question
will we follow him
all
the way
that's the question
i want you to be soaking in today in
this whole week will we follow him all
the way
there's a um
a beautiful old hymn
familiar probably to many of you titled
oh the wonderful cross
some of you know this remember this i
know we don't do a ton of hymns here at
the table hopefully it hasn't left your
mind
if you're familiar it's it's um i'm to
sing just a little bit of it's just the
course if you know it please sing with
me so it's not a solo
all right so this is just the chorus all
right you guys remember it
oh the
wonderful cross oh y'all have nice oh
the
wonderful
cross
bids me come and die
to find that i
may truly
live
it's beautiful
i'm sorry for anyone who didn't know it
and felt a little left out it's okay
hopefully you're still able to
participate
i love that last line bits me come and
die
to find that i
may truly live
it was a
14th century uh mystic meister eckhart
he said most people when they think of
christian faith they think it's all
about addition
i need to add something to my life i
don't have
primarily god
that's kind of how it says we often
think of it you know christ i need i
need some jesus in my life
so i'm gonna go to church
and be real good and hope
that like the magic happens for me and
my life gets better
once i've got god you know alongside me
and my guard said said nope
nope that's a that's a misunderstanding
he said
because
the god who is father son holy spirit
the god who is loving relationship
itself right first john says god is love
that god is always already present to
you in the very depths of your being
there's no like adding like okay god
please join me please be present to me
boy i hope you get involved in my life
like oh god god is present to you he
says the so it's not about addition
what's it about
subtraction
he says it's about a letting go
letting go because god is present
it's it's our own well i mean just think
of the
the mission here at the table to shift a
generation from reactionary to visionary
to the personal work of jesus what's
reactionary
that's that mess inside all of us you
know that that bitterness anger that ego
just going
just going wild and messing up our lives
and relationships and right it's like
that's that thing that god's present
god's working christ is faithful always
it's that other part of us
that mess it up and so my star card said
what what this is about it's a
subtraction it's a letting go and i was
thinking like okay well let him go i'm
gonna give you something more concrete
though letting go of what a letting go
man well it's different for every person
of course right so let me just give you
a few options it's a letting go of um my
need to be right
man i need to win
letting go of my demand for success
letting go of um
our insane addictions
that like feel good in the moment but
then leave us
miserable
uh letting go of our need for people's
approval
letting go of that that that dangerous
part of us that that kind of needs to
dominate
our desire to have it all together
or at least appear as though
we have it all together
our obsession with needy nothing and no
one
that's big in america
especially in texas
my insecurities and fears
my greed
my pride
my envy
it's a it's a letting go not about
addition oh god please join no no god's
present christ is
present the spirit is active and working
i mean how do you think anything in the
world works at all
god is present
the miracle is the letting go
this is what the book of philippians
calls a self-empting
it's what jesus talked about when he
said if
anyone wants to come after me they must
take up their cross and
follow
me
when jesus also said
you can gain the whole world
and yet lose your soul
right this is a willing god i want to
die to those things
i want to let those things go
maybe sum it up like this you need
something like concrete
i'll put it like this faith begins
on the mountaintop
of victory
and miracle
it begins there and it's not bad that's
okay i'm not trying to like shame you oh
those people shouting hallelujah they
were so so shallow they just wanted
miracles and breakthrough in power and
victory
it's not bad we all start there faith
begins there
faith matures in the valley
matures
in the valley of trial and suffering
heartache loss
sickness
divorce
mental illness
kids
losing their minds
struggling
fear
right that's that's where it starts it
starts to mature
in those moments i was uh
never a good gardener but i did have one
garden
and uh
it didn't go so well because i uh i grew
my plants but i grew them under a grow
light and i only kept them inside
experienced gardeners know you gotta
like once they start sprouting you gotta
get them outside
and what happened was i grew those
little plants and they were i mean y'all
they were growing like it was amazing
they were like so tall
and i took them outside
and to plant them and they all what came
out the next morning and they'd all just
fallen over
just
because what happens is if they're not
if the plants aren't out in the elements
they have to basically get used to the
wind
and the struggle
and that that's how they get strong
is in that process i didn't know i
thought i was protecting my little
plants like oh this is genius like
they'll be so protected
i think this is where god and his wisdom
i don't think he brings the trials
because honestly trials come this
world's bananas
suffer you don't have to seek out more
suffering in the world you know like go
to monastery wear a hair shirt or
something like you don't have to do that
just live and there'll be plenty
of trials but that's that's the place we
grow right we love the mountaintops we
love the breakthrough we love the
victory we love those moments and yes
and amen that's good
but we grow in the valley
and and that's the picture when we
follow jesus all the way where it's a
willingness to follow him all the way to
the cross
to go through the valley of suffering
and not jump out and be like well i quit
so i didn't sign up for this
you know this is the problem with
something in theology called the
prosperity gospel
um
you know which isn't in of itself isn't
necessarily technically wrong you know
because it's like god wants you to be
blessed god wants you to be victorious
god wants breakthrough for you and
victory and miracle and it's like yeah
that's true
true but what it kind of shades away
from is like
yeah but that process still involves
struggle and heartache and like there's
still suffering in the world it's not
like we don't get to go detour around
that are you tracking
right
and so that's the invitation now this
can all sound a little bit maybe well
not a little it can sound quite gloomy
quite intimidating and maybe a little
scary like i don't know if i'm up for
that journey
you know
[Music]
i wanna i'll close with this this little
story um beautiful story uh
and uh it's it's the story of
um
when the disciples this is uh matthew
chapter 14 the disciples they're in a
boat
uh just the twelve no jesus is not in
the boo
and bo and they're on the sea of galilee
a storm kicks up sea of galilee by the
way is famous for its storms something
about the valley and the mountains and
how things have like just big old storms
so there they are and this of course two
thousand years ago boats weren't awesome
you know ship buildings come a long way
they're not on a cruise ship people you
know it's like oh storm how exciting you
know like no not exciting with those
little boats you know
not fun at all so there they are storm
kicks up they're freaking out
freaky now suddenly they see in the
distance a figure
walking on the water
uh this only adds it just escalates
their freak out uh
one of the bible literally says one of
the disciples scream out it's a ghost
that's what they yelled out it's like a
three-year-old it's a ghost and they're
freaking out and of course it's jesus he
says don't be afraid it's me and peter
remember peter he says uh
well this is his moment right some of
you guys remember the story he says if
it is you
let me
come out to you
and what does jesus say
come on
and so there he goes
peter keeping his eyes on jesus he
starts to
walk on the water let's talk about a
moment of miracle breakthrough victory
and it's the whole thing
right he's wise walking on the water
and then the bible says but then peter
did what with his eyes
he starts looking at the waves
and the wind
and that's the moment he starts to sink
isn't that a perfect picture of our life
like we're okay as long as we keep our
eyes on jesus you know and of course i
mean this in uh somewhat of a
metaphorical sense right not like
literally have a picture of jesus in
your wallet or purse and anytime you're
going through a hard time look at a
picture you know like no it's it's back
to meister eckhart right christ is
present to you god is present to you in
the very depths of your being this has
always been the case and it's a matter
of tuning in and keep staying centered
and rooted and grounded there
right because
the moment we take our eyes off of
christ and start to focus on our valleys
and suffering and the wind and the waves
we start freaking out
and so
really if you're wondering how will i do
this how will i follow jesus all the way
that's the way you just keep your eyes
there you just keep grounded rooted
centered
in the god who is father son holy spirit
so that's really the invitation this
this holy week
is let's let's stay focused on christ
and specifically because that's that's
how we start the process of transition
from
miracle
to
maturity
growing up
which is god's will for each and every
one of us
so as we come to the table of the lord
today
what i'd like us to keep in mind is is
kind of that commitment
right as we partake of the bread
symbolizing his broken body his blood
symbolizing the wine that it's this
moment of okay jesus i want to keep my
eyes on you no matter what i'm going
through no other no matter what valley
of suffering i'm going through i want to
keep my eyes on you
i want to follow you all the way
that's what we're doing as we come
forward and so i want to invite you to
the table but not in not in our usual
way instead i want to invite you to pray
this is a prayer of confession
and um
it'll be on the screen
so i want to i want to invite you to
actually just
read it along
with me
all right let's pray
god
of all times and places
we confess that we would rather join the
crowds than stand alone
we prefer the popular point of view to a
solitary witness for justice and truth
we like safety and security while
shrinking from the risk of involvement
we'll sing hosanna when everyone else is
doing so
but not when the hostile good friday
forces may hear us
we do not like to admit our lukewarm
response to you
but neither do we want to be considered
fanatics
we believe jesus christ came into the
world to save sinners
we know that means us
not just other folks involved in obvious
evils everyone knows about
we ask you to be patient with us
to help us understand our own guilt
then pour out your forgiveness in such a
way that we are forever transformed
in the name of the father the son and
the holy spirit
amen
separation
[Music]
we're
is
[Music]
his is
and so
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
stronger
oh
[Music]
so
is
[Music]
please
uh
[Music]
us
so
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
my
well thank you again for joining us
tonight
and uh
a reminder friday seven o'clock here
and then easter sunday blue heron event
in landing
venue
and uh it's actually technically in
wiley just over the line and that'll be
at 10 30 a.m so don't come at five
o'clock
also any i don't know if palm branches
have been collected but if not you just
leave them on your seat um we're gonna
return those to pleasant valley umc
so let me um send you out with this
benediction if you want to go ahead and
stand to your feet
[Music]
if you're comfortable you can raise your
hands just to receive
uh and participate in this
may the god
whose arms were spread on the cross
to embrace the whole world
help all of us this week
to take up our own cross
and follow
him amen
go in peace
[Music]
stronger
you